let's jump to this viral story this
one's so good ladies and gentlemen we
have this from The Daily Mail
pregnant New York City nurse accused of
taking a city bike from a black man
outside hospital is named as friends
start GoFundMe to pay her legal bills
and lawyer shares receipts that proves
the bike was hers all right here's the
story a viral video over the weekend
showed a white woman yelling for help
as some black teenagers surround her and
one guy has his hand on the bike saying
this is not your bike this is my bike
they started claiming that she was
racist that she was trying to steal the
bike from this young black man and that
she was putting his safety in Jeopardy
the hospital suspended her pending an
investigation
we have this tweet from Ben Crump he
said this is unacceptable a white woman
was caught on camera attempting to steal
a city bike from a young black man in
New York City she grossly tried to
weaponize her tears to paint this man as
a threat this is exactly the type of
behavior that has endangered so many
black men in the past the first thing I
noticed when I see this is that she's
actually on the bike
she's literally on the bike and he's not
and he's grabbing the bike and laughing
so how is it so these City bikes the way
they work they're in the rack you walk
up you scan the QR code and the unlocks
the bike and you can take it out how is
it that he walked up did not get on the
bike scanned it then did she run up at
this pregnant woman she's six months
pregnant by the way did she run up and
jump on the bike and try taking it from
him that's what Ben Crump is arguing so
her lawyer so this is the story that was
going out not only did they go they put
out a story saying that she was a racist
trying to steal the bike from this black
teenager journalists went to her home in
New York City and started going to her
neighbors and and saying look this this
is your neighbor this is what she did
what do you think and there are these
people being like wow that looks racist
I can't believe she would do that think
about how nightmarish it is to live in
one of these places I can't even imagine
wanting to live in a place like that
where you have to worry about uh the
media going to your neighbors accusing
you of racism and a totally fabricated
story Ben Crump is the most incredible
race Hustler I have ever seen in my life
that dude is Shameless and he he just
gets on any any court case or whatever
that he can he's just right there
planting his uh his flag looking for
them dollars so wait so she had the
receipts that showed that this was her
bike this guy was trying to take it from
her on what basis did he decide to
report that she was stealing the bike
from him just the picture he saw the
picture and said well well she has the
best they filmed it okay they they
filmed her and and said like this is
brilliant stuff this is Con level
brilliant grifting when you're
committing the crime accuse the other
person of committing the crime and film
them and then if they don't give you
what you want you can upload the video
and make them the bad guy that's Rules
for Radicals right I would use your
opponent of what you're doing I was
talking about this when I I did a
segment for my morning show an old
contract called a reverse pickpocket
what you do is you take a wallet with a
night with you put your ID in it like an
old dummy ID and then maybe some I don't
know a couple bucks or something you
slip it into the bag of bag or pocket of
someone else then accuse them of robbing
you and that this gets other bystanders
or even the police wow to Rob them on
your behalf so what happens is you say
help that person just robbed me and they
took my phone they took my they took my
wallet and then phone's hard because
yeah yeah but if you say they took my
wallet you can say they took other
things too exactly yeah so so the way
the com would work is you drop the dummy
wallet in their coat pocket or something
then you call the police or you you ask
for help when they when they say look in
his pocket the victim is going what are
you talking about I didn't do anything
and they go empty your pockets then the
person pulls a wall out of their pocket
there it is that's my wallet open it's
got my ID in it when they open it and
your ID's in it they say boom this
proves it and I say and my cash I had 40
bucks in there no there's no cash in
there where's my 40 bucks and they take
the 40 bucks from the victim and give it
to you you can actually get police to
arrest the victims and then they'll
often just be like here's your cash flow
sorry there's an old con people used to
pull and there's sophisticated versions
of it too they wait till someone leaves
an ATM and then people will leave the
receipts at the ATM showing how much
money they have on them then your body
reverse pickpockets then you call the
police and say that person did it the
wallet on them is proof the cop doesn't
even need to get a statement or any
evidence the wallet on them is proven
off and the cop will say upon stopping
the perpetrator we found the wallet in
question proving that the theft took
place we returned the money to the
victim wow crazy right this is what
these guys are basically doing they're
they're trying to you know here's what I
think they were trying to do
when this this happens a lot with these
with these Bike Share things you unlock
the bike with your phone and then you
ride it around and it charges you I
think per hour or you can be a member or
something so what they'll do is they'll
wait for someone to unlock a bike take
the bike from them and then bike stairs
yeah bikes on them because the bike
doesn't have a camera on or anything
like that so you can't you can't track
and now if if I use my phone to unlock a
bike and they take it it's all on you
I'll pay for it that's right I paid for
it I think they were trying to steal the
bike from her to get away with it they
said she's stealing the bike from me and
it actually worked for a second until
she was able to publish the receipts
proving it was actually her bike they
took from her wow crazy right that is
really crazy who wants to live in this
place this is this is in New York
Hustler's gonna hustle yeah yeah look at
this this is uh what is it it's right by
just just north of Union Square
they can reveal the nurses City bike
receipts which your lawyer claims proves
the number on the handlebars of the bike
she was clutching in the footage so you
can see in the picture
560-3915 and they published the receipt
560-3915 wow
welcome to to the the new country I
guess well he also immediately took it
to not just a race-baiting place a
racist Place she's weaponizing her white
woman Tears like you mean she's crying
because someone's trying to steal her
bike from her I don't think she was
really crying though it does seem fake
like they accused her of fake crying and
the reason I think a lot of people cited
against her is that she's screaming for
help no one helps her then she grabs his
phone then they grab it back then she
starts crying and then the guy behind
her goes get a different bike and then
she just gets off the bike and stops
crying
so I kind of feel like she wasn't as
distressed as she's making out to be but
she was still the victim trying to
figure out how to win this in some way
because she doesn't have the physical
ability to do so and part of me is just
kind of like I'm gonna say it I'm gonna
say it guys she lives in New York the
likelihood that a woman a millennial
woman in New York voted conservative or
for law order is almost zero she likely
but but you know what I'm hoping it's
stuff like this that wakes people like
her up right
true that's what you hope for but it
never never seems to she's why I don't
live there yeah that's why I decide not
to live in these places we we keep
saying over and over people should get
out of New York City get out of the
cities and stuff I mean every day you
see more and more people that can't
leave
speaking up and saying things like I
miss Rudy Giuliani like we saw that
woman today and you know the people that
are on the uh the subway are happy that
the guy saved him because there are
people that can't leave and it's it's
you know hard for some people to just be
like I gotta up and you know if you got
family or if you don't have a lot of
money or whatever there's a million
reasons people could be attached to to a
city but when you hear the average
person that's stuck and can't leave
start saying I missed the guy that was
the Law and Order guy that has also been
basically lambasted for the past six
seven years in the in the media because
he supported the wrong president you
know when you've got all of that
propaganda but New Yorkers are still
like I remember what it was like when
Giuliani was the was the mayor and I
want that back you know you get people
saying things like they want Michael
Bloomberg back and that's that that's
really the population speaking about
what they want you know I can't imagine
what it's like to be stuck there and I
feel I feel terrible for the people they
are they launched a GoFundMe for her
and uh I think she's going to be in for
a rude awakening when GoFundMe bans
their their their fundraising effort
because GoFundMe is the left and give
send go is the right this woman her
family they don't know what's going on
they don't understand I would not be
surprised if GoFundMe removes this
because she is a racist white woman who
tried stealing a bike from a black man
and she's a Karen and then she's gonna
have to learn the hard way why she'll
have to go but but maybe not maybe maybe
GoFundMe allows it I'd be surprised if
they do to be honest
she's raised four grand so far over 35
000 goal well
no I mean it's interesting how this is
getting flipped around people are making
the argument that her calls for help
were insincere okay but one person is
actually committing a crime on camera
here and it's not her so why is she the
person who all the public attention is
on I also want to point out because this
was left out and I also was not aware of
this until I just learned that she's
also pregnant
six months pregnant yes I said oh you do
okay sorry that totally went over my
head and so I'm saying like what when
this young black man was was standing
next to the bike and scanning it this
six months pregnant oh yeah that's right
jumps onto the bike give me that dude
he's six months pregnant women stealing
bikes from black men in New York is a
real problem happens every day
apparently yeah apparently it was so
shocking because Donald Trump had to get
involved yeah
like what do they think is I don't
understand what they think is happening
like this pregnant woman tried taking a
bike from this group of men a race a
note a racist pregnant because they
brought race into it she was using her
white woman tears a racist white woman
like these pregnant white women are
victimizing minorities by stealing their
bikes it doesn't stop happening are they
are they saying that this pregnant white
woman saw a group a group of young black
teenagers walked up to them and said
give me that bike and then jumped on it
right it's just wild to me that's what
they're actually going and she had to
prove her innocence because the media
was saying she made them unsafe because
Ben Crump called her racist unreal you
know look man I I
do you expect me to donate to her as
well
like the penny thing I get they're
trying to put him in prison you know
what I mean they did try destroying This
Woman's life but this is why I said it
before and I'll say it again at what
point
are these people in these cities
this is this is what they how they
choose to live
yeah yeah I I get it we've gotta we've
gotta win these fights
maybe maybe the reason we donate to her
is because we want people to see that if
you know you will not be victimized by
these these these con artists well this
is the problem right I mean you can
donate to people who this kind of thing
happens to and I think that's a good
thing but when the people who perpetrate
the lies don't face any negative
consequences it just keeps happening
there's literally zero downside to
spreading a lie like this you know you
know what I was thinking we were we were
talking about
um
we're talking about we're talking about
history earlier and it's uh partly
because the work we're doing in West
Virginia these are small towns and I was
saying like any any story you've heard
throughout history just imagine it with
a hundred times less people
because we're used to growing up in
these big dense Urban environments or we
see like a we see like a football game
and there's 60 000 people and we're like
wow so when you think back to the
Coliseum you're imagining this huge full
Coliseum and the gliders fight it's
probably a couple hundred people yeah
like just a few hundred these Great
Battles of History and we're imagining
and it's like I think I think what was
Gettysburg like 10 15 000 or something
like that oh no no way more more people
died at Gettysburg than died in the
entire Vietnam War oh wow well I knew
that more um
Americans died in uh the Civil War was
something like 700 000 Americans died in
the the Civil War overall yeah more
people died at Gettysburg than died in
the whole Vietnam War there was 54 50
some thousand people died in Vietnam and
there was more people that died at the
oh wow yeah it was 160 000 people
present at Gettysburg that's a lot of
people a lot of people so okay civil war
Civil War excluded
because I was like reading about some
historical fight and it was mentioning
like this great battle and it was a few
hundred people fighting and I was like
oh well we we think by today's standards
and maybe because of the Civil War we
assume there's way more people but there
were a lot less people before the 1900s
before the Industrial Revolution yeah
before the before the you know I mean we
talk about oh like energy is life and
there's all this talk about you know
limiting energy and there's a lot of the
green initiatives and stuff that's just
going to cause Mass death because energy
is life if you look at a chart of world
population it's not just the Industrial
Revolution it's oil oil is so energy
dense that once people discovered that
oil could be used in all the things that
it can be the population on Earth
skyrocketed I mean it's like it's
literally like it makes Lance's uh
left-handed chart look ridiculous I mean
it's straight up left-handed Church well
so Colby I'd like to ask and obviously
don't answer if this is not something
you're public about but uh do you or
have you ever had to live in one of
these blue places
yeah yeah I had to live in Oregon for
most of my life and you know it wasn't
as political they didn't you know make
it so you know so much division like
there is today and and left first right
and trying to make it a white versus
black thing to divide this country more
so it was never like that until like a
couple years ago when antifa started
raiding it and you know it just became
such a democrat-run state so it's this
time of day is just so much different
than it was you know a decade ago and so
you you grew up there yeah that must be
really hard to see it fall apart yeah
it's really hard because I I love that
that state it's such a beautiful you
know State yeah a lot of mountains a lot
of outdoor stuff to do and you know
that's why I was born and raised and
that's where all the hard work was put
into to get to where I am today the top
of the mountain of the UFC world so you
know I'll never go back now seeing it
the way it's run I'll never go back I
don't I don't even go to visit you know
so yeah somebody somebody to ask a good
question they said why is it on the
receipt the time is blurred out as if to
imply that she went back later to find
this bike I'll say two things the first
I'll say a couple things I have no idea
you want to pull this up I have no idea
why they uh blurred the time on the
receipt that's the Daily Mail
but you wouldn't be able to find the
bike like if someone took the bike and
then rode away with it you don't know
where it would end up the other thing is
the New York Post says the first receipt
reviewed by the post shows the bike was
taken out before it was re-locked one
minute later which Moreno said is the
bike scene in the video the second
receipt shows another bike being taken
out a minute later which is the bike she
switched to so the story was that when
she was she she purchased the bike and
tried to take it they they pushed her
back in and wouldn't let her leave with
it which is why the receipt says zero
because it was it was it was unlocked
and then re-locked right away so that's
the bike and you can see the the number
on the on the bike in question but other
than that I have no idea where the Daily
Mail I'm I'm assuming it looks at the
Daily Mail is the one that redacted the
uh the time stamp on it for some reason
yeah no idea
yep very strange thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there